quatre jours après s'être échouées
le fbi n'a pas bougé malgré l' opération
de dragage et de remorquage reconnu à ce
moment-ci cf que le dragage autour de
l'avant du navire va suffire ou est-ce
qu'il faut alléger navire ici faut aller
vers une opération d'allongement du
navire donc de déchargement partielle de
sa carrière faudra-t-il des jours ou des
semaines pour déplacer le cargo de 400
mètres de long et de 2 120 mille tonnes
qui bloque le canal de suez une route
commerciale cruciale entre l'europe et
l'asie où transitent plus d'un milliard
de tonnes de marchandises par an soit
10% du commerce maritime mondial
deux forts vents et une tempête de sable
aurait causé l'incident
depuis c'est tout le secteur qui tourne
au ralenti et senna votre ruse comme
personne n'en connaît les répercussions
sur les coûts sont inévitables 3,7
externe qui rappelle que le transport
maritime nous apporte encore 90% de tous
surtout que des centaines de navires
tourner en rond coincé forcés
d'emprunter un détour vers le cap de
bonne espérance
des milliers de kilomètres pour
contourner l'afrique
ça représente un ajout de ses séjours
sur un voyage qui peut durer près de
trois semaines pendant des escales etc
donc c'est quand même que conséquent ici
ça perdure ça va mettre une pression
très importante sur les chaînes
d'approvisionnement surtout pour les
marchés européens des marchés déjà mises
à mal par la pandémie
le blocage du canal de suez a aussi fait
monter les prix du pétrole
une raison qui a poussé les états unis à
offrir leur aide aux autorités
égyptiennes pour éviter que la situation
s'éternise
issigeac audrey charbonneau raid au
canada mon frère